This is the Chris Abraham show.
Welcome to the priests Abraham
show.
This is season 4 episode 21 that
day Venta that they are bent a
Gente.
No swans.
Anyway, today is about date on
my slow.
Rowing progress.
I'm so happy To have you here.
So happy, you're back here.
I've been trying to deal with
issues of the recording being
low.
So I will try to check every I
will always check and then I
will try to replace the voice
files with.
I will try to replace the voice
files with compressed and
normalized files.
If it's too low, when I'm
listening to it, I'm still
trying to tweak the recorder.
So anyway, I want to give you a
report.
It is last night was day, 6 of
my growing every night in a
perfect world.
Rowing 10,000 meters every
night, but I only did I only did
50 something minutes yesterday.
Anyway, I'll be right back.
Welcome back.
This is the Chris Abraham show,
nay formerly known as Chris
cast.
This is season 4 episode 21 and
my name is Chris Abraham.
So I started a group on Facebook
called slow rowing.
But apparently, I previously
started a group called slow row,
which I think sounds better, but
you let me know which one we're
going to go with because I also
have a slow row subreddit and a
slow rowing subreddit.
The reason why I chose slow
rowing is because I also created
slow jogging, which is a which
is a whole thing designed by a
doctor in or an intellectual in
Japan who decided that Spending
the rest of your life.
Rowing sorry, run a jogging
slowly at a shuffles Pace to the
point where you can smile be
happy, do it forever and carry
on.
A conversation is the best way
to get fit because it's you're
the least likely to get injured.
You're the least likely to get
sore, you're the least likely to
hate doing it and it's the kind
of thing that you can do with.
Almost very literally your
street clothes on.
But as I am, as big as a house,
currently, I've decided to take
everything that I've learned
from my research about slow
jogging and Also the map atone
method and all those other
things and in addition to a
book, I call slow row.
I think it's like breathe.
And it's, I think, by a guy
named DP Ordway, he came out
with the book where he basically
says that there's nothing wrong
and everything, good about
getting onto a concept to or, or
other type of rowing machine.
And Rowing moderately.
Now, I've taken moderately to
the newest level because I
encourage you to row as row as
slowly as you want.
Just make sure that, you know,
you keep the tension on the
chain of your rower.
And don't literally pretend like
you are in slow motion, but
just, you know, row row row.
Your boat gently down the
stream.
As I said before row as though
you're in Central Park, you're
on the lake or the pond and
you've just with your with your
paramour and you pay for a
rowboat and your street clothes
and your and your nights.
Nice street clothes because
you're on a date, it's either
your date night or a first or
second date or Whatever and
you're there to impress and
you're there to seduce and
you're there to romance.
So what you need to do is get
into the boat and start rowing
enjoy the Sun but don't initiate
flop, sweat, and don't initiate
it.
Darkening and do not become
competitive where you are,
huffing and puffing.
Ying, do not make sure that
you're able to remain with
enough breath.
So as to woo, so as to recite
love poems, or mention your
appreciation for the beautiful
day or the beautiful person
across from you.
And that is what slow-rolling
is.
So, yesterday, was day, six of
the rest of my life, and while I
didn't do an hour, our I did
close to an hour and by close to
an hour, I can tell you I did.
Love, love, love, I did about 58
minutes out of an hour and about
almost almost 10,000 meters.
So it was technically
successful.
But one thing that I did do,
okay, so the first five days I
really was just LOL.
Lala and mostly my Pace per 500
meters was 310, 305 320.
But yesterday I did a hard 20
and my rate went down, you know,
2128.
That's that can't be true.
Yeah. 1128 150, that kind of
thing.
So, Like I was stepping it up.
Here's the thing I need to
remind you though, even though,
if you're very sedentary which I
assume you are considering you
want to do, you want to slow Row
for the rest of your life.
You want to perform moderate
exercise.
So as to keep your body limber,
Nimble, functional flexible,
mobile and healthy.
I assume that you are just
starting out.
And so it's really important to
take my, you know, description,
literally row slow.
I don't want you to ever be out
of breath.
I don't want to really even
sweat on them on the rower. but
what I'm going to tell you is
that after a couple days of this
doing this every night, when you
get in and out of the shower or
whatever, you're going to feel
your muscles You're not going to
feel the kind of pain you get
after CrossFit or after
Sprint's, or after doing weight
lifting with the trainer at the
gym.
But you were going to feel,
you're going to feel your
hamstrings, you're going to feel
your glutes, you're going to
feel your quads.
There's going to be tightness in
there.
I haven't started stretching
yet, but I think I'm probably
going to start stretching
because I do not want to have
Hamstrings and that sort of
thing because I don't want to
not up.
I don't want to end up having
any lower back problems or
problems with my my lumbago.
Or my various and Sundry nerves
pinching.
And but I want you to know that
that's that'll show you that
even if you just exercise for an
hour every day, even at the
lowest lowest stroke rate in the
lowest intensity, your body is
going to benefit from it.
And you tell me if you follow
this plan after a few days,
whether or not getting in and
out of the shower is just, you
can feel a little bit more.
A little bit more, I don't know,
stiffness in your tendons a
little bit more soreness in your
in your hamstrings and glutes
and that sort of thing.
So I think that's very
encouraging but I also have been
watching some really good movies
and the next episode, I will
tell you about some of the
movies I've been watching, but I
think it's a great opportunity
to really get In there and I
really encourage myself and my
goal from now on is to try to
aim at doing a full 90 minutes
per per row, you know, so that I
can match the general watch time
of a movie as opposed to having
to, you know, do two thirds and
then leave one third remaining.
So I am going to try to match my
exercise.
No reason to honk.
I'm going to try to match my
exercising to the length of what
I watch.
That's not the case when I watch
dramas, right?
Is dramas are about 45 minutes,
complete.
If I watch them on YouTube TV
that have tons of commercials,
maybe it'll even be an hour, but
if I choose something like a
drama I'll watch it on YouTube
TV with commercials or on Hulu.
If I I'm watching a comedy and
it's only half an hour watch to,
but if it's a movie, like if
it's a good movie and I am
enjoying it, I'm really going to
try to make it for the whole 90
minutes or 2 hours.
And in addition to that, I'm
going to write a little movie
review in my notes section of my
journal and I will hopefully
have some recommendations for
you in a couple episodes or
maybe even the next episode.
What else?
I personally have a lot of
cushions on top of my rowing
seat because, you know, I'm in
it for the long haul and I don't
want, you know, a sort.
But to get in the way I find
that on my, on my, on my spin
bike, I find that I'm dissuaded
because of Of the time it takes
for your bottom, to get used to
a bike seat.
So the ERG doesn't have anything
like that for me, but I do have
four or five foam concept to
adhesive pads on on the seats.
So there's that.
What else?
Make sure you drink water before
during, and after hydration is
really important, you don't
realize it but even low
intensity workout for an hour.
Burns, you know, for three,
four, five, hundred calories.
So you are, you know, you are
working, even though it doesn't
feel like it in the same way
that if you walk for an hour or
two, you are, you are
exercising, you know, whether no
matter how casually you do it
anyway, I guess I'll stop now
and I will talk to you soon.
I hope you're well and after the
break, we'll come the contact
info talk to you soon.
Love you.
Bye.
Welcome back.
Welcome back, welcome back.
My name is Chris Abraham.
This is the Chris Abraham Show
episode for season.
Sorry, Season 4 Episode 21.
I do declare.
My name is Chris Abraham and my
contact info is as follows.
I am Chris at Abraham .s, you
You I am plus 1 20 to 35 to 50
51.
You can text me or call me.
You can use WhatsApp or signal
or telegram to find me on
telegram.
I am at Garris Court.
I think at ger is you are P or
maybe at ger is I don't know.
I just know.
That's the one thing I didn't
get Chris Abraham. or but I'm
also on calendly.com, Chris
Abraham / 15 and I am
Twitter.com slash Chris Abraham,
facebook.com slash Chris,
Abraham instagram.com, sighs,
Chris Abraham, youtube.com slash
Chris Abraham.
I am facebook.com slash this
Abraham, although I think I just
said that I am Chris Dash
Abraham.com for Tumblr and I'm
Chris Abraham.com for my
personal website and I need to
work on that and dumb thing
because I am dumb when I say,
and and thank you so much for
coming.
Next episode is season 4
episode, 22 and who knows,
what'll it be about.
This isn't really one of those
folks things, and I can tell
that it's time to go because
there are helicopters coming and
helicopters.
I think are very audible things.
So I think I'm just going to cut
it and I will talk to you soon.
Love you alveta.
Zane choose to Mom bientot, to
Tyler.
Hasta luego, hasta mañana.
She see how he does.
In fact,
thank you for listening to the
Chris Abraham show.
Make sure you subscribe.
So you don't miss any future
episodes until next time.